welcome to bananamores this next comic
is responsible for most of my wrinkles
caused by all the laugh lines
you think i was on the floor
oh thank thank you so much
thank you you you've held me down you've
held me down for so long y'all might not
know this
but when i was down and out you know i
was on i was on a big plush banana couch
able to get back on my feet back when i
was hitting set
and only only only mitzi had me thank
you
i know i know i'm supposed to be real
goofy right now but i had to i had to
get that off my heart
real quick i had to get that off my
heart uh but yeah we have a nice
intimate set here we you know we got all
the anime figures sitting around you
goku's funko pops you know they they
watching
i'm having a good time i'm ready to get
back out here this has been it's been a
long quarantine it's been a
it's been a long quarantine i don't know
how all of y'all's quarantine been but
mine
i've been buying stuff i've been buying
so much stuff which is why i'm staring
at so many anime figures right now
but i i've even been letting the social
media algorithm just pitch things at me
and
seeing you know what i want to buy and
it made sense at first
at first it was making sense you know it
was like black hair care products you
know fitness things things that apply to
me the algorithm was working
but i think i was buying too much
because at some point
the algorithm got confused and it just
started just throwing whatever it could
they're like he'll buy it so let's just
get the weird stuff
let's just get the weird stuff and like
one time
it even like pitched at me a backyard
beekeeping kit
sometime i didn't even have a backyard
so that was weird
uh even even more so i don't know a
single
black person that messes with bees i
don't know a single one
if you know a black person that messes
with bees
that's that's the candy man so you
should start running you should get away
i can only do that joke four more times
then he comes to kill me those are the
rules
hope you hope you up
another quarantine core purchase
gorgeous
as as as i may say sometimes i've got a
got an electric vehicle i was like i'm
gonna leave it i'm gonna leave gas
in 2020. i'm gonna get an electric
vehicle but i got one of them
self-driving joints
uh and and i'm hyped i was i was real
hyped to get a self-driving car
but the thing they don't tell you about
getting a self-driving car is the things
that you're excited about
uh no one else is gonna be excited about
like like i'll be talking about with my
friends like yo
this self-driving is tight man i was
able to fall asleep for five
minutes while driving and nothing
happened and they're like bro
you shouldn't be doing that what you
talking about what you talking about
like that's why we get he's like no no i
don't want you out on the road anymore
i don't want you out in the room but i
think i'm thinking look this is how we
go in the future
let's let's stop driving ourselves let
the car do the drive you know there's
too much human error
i may be the only one who believes this
but i'm gonna
let's ride into the future if you got a
self-driving car i don't want you all
use me as excuse for falling asleep
behind the wheel all right
all right all right look i got to get
out of here
mitzi said don't take too much time up
here so you know i got a split
even though it's been appealing set but
i got a haul potassium
yeah you knew you were gonna get some
banana fans i can't be behind a giant
banana
and not do a few banana puns but i'm
getting up out of here
i'll see you later look somebody get
another drink to goku right here
somebody get goku another drink because
that that's been empty
for my whole set so let's get you out of
here but i'm gonna give it back to mitzi
thanks for for watching me taking time
out of yo day
uh and i'll see you all next time was
that good for you
it was good for me and it was good for
the banana
ah yes this next performer
she really lights up the banana more
stage
thank you mitchie i love you uh
hey everybody um thank you so much i i
can't believe y'all stayed in to see me
this is absolutely amazing um
i've been really trying to focus on the
positives this year you know
i'm actually so so excited about online
school
but i have a lisp and a bad coordination
when i run i have the gate of a poorly
constructed marionette also i'm pretty
sure i'm flat-footed and
last year i got stuck in the bathroom
stall in school and i missed the
entirety
of our orientation pizza party not great
and
because i couldn't do the latch like
it's actually like very very hard you
know right like it's just it's so
hard and that's why when someone walks
in on me i'm actually kind of relieved
you know like
oh thank god it opens people can have
that attitude more often like
oh hey you're here come on in
it's awkward again our country needs
more cordial conversation
that's why you know at least feel free
to use this i
always carry around confetti so if
someone does walk in on me
i just make it a party yeah surprise
no amanda she's the most popular girl in
my school
she i mean she just is but uh she was
not having it with me
joining the skinny babes group chat she
was like
um who does she think she is and um
this year we have no school pictures
which is like a big positive because i
hate school pictures and and it's not
even just school pictures
it's also like reshoot day which is when
your parents open up the envelope and
they look at the little photo and
they're like
no no i'm not i'm not paying for this
i'm just not
paying there i was on the reshoot line
seriously if it didn't work out the
first time
i have the same face yes
ah my mother would like to order the
reshoot
amanda's face please thank you
um except for you know like we really
should be kinder to one another
and that's something i've learned a lot
during quarantine is that we really have
to more understanding of people like
like you know i have to be understanding
of even people like like my mom who
who has a giant bag of socks that's just
been living in the corner of our living
room for years now
and i just have to be understanding of
that
but i'm i did confront her about it
the other day ago i was like hey mom
what's up with the bag of socks and she
was like
this is a bag of
socks i saved so you and your sisters
could make puppets
first i felt kind of bad you know never
freaking occurred to me to make a
freaking puppet like i had no idea my
mom was harboring this dream
of me becoming the next jim henson but
then i was like
wait a second i've actually never
shown a single affinity towards puppets
so this isn't about me mom it's about
you
and then she got really quiet she went
why did i do it what did it get me
bags of socks me with a vacuum gluing
buttons
what does it get you what does it get
you
i had a dream i dreamed it
for you maybe it wasn't for me
maybe um
so now i'm making puppets please
please visit my etsy page uh
thanks for having me thank you thanks so
much bye
[Applause]
oh that's funny i can't even get over
how much
talent this person has it's downright
unfair
bananamores makes me hungry for more
comedians like this next one
oh camera thank you mitzi
it's nice to have a place to perform
during the pandemic
actually i don't even call it the
pandemic i've been referring to this
time as
that year it was okay to wear natural
deodorant
guys i got youtube heckled the other day
and i get it you need a place to be able
to take out your negative energy
i get it but this lady it was annoying
she said
in my comments she said well
disappointing because
i thought mary mac would be younger
yeah i was younger one time
where were you you you're late to the
game here
right and also like
i'm just aging according to nature
like i'm doing my job you know
like are you heckling me or are you
heckling the processes of time
like that if you don't like the way the
earth spins
don't talk to me about it like talk to
whoever you think
is in charge of that whatever supreme
being talk to the manager i only work
here
on earth
uh can you imagine like she was
probably pretty disappointed at the
beginning of that video she watched but
can you imagine
how extremely upset she would be
by the end of it because i would be
45 minutes older at that point
boy she'd be pissed right like um
every day is downhill for this woman can
you imagine
what else she uh heckles people about
oh i didn't like how mary abided by the
laws of gravity and then just float off
into the sky during her skit
[Applause]
the punch line of that joke is a
middle-aged woman
growling that's me
so uh you said i was pretty good at
science right
well i'm also gifted at the metric
system because um i
uh in school they said well you gotta
learn the metric system because this is
the way the country's going
and canada might invade so like you
gotta be ready to do business with the
mounties
you know so i studied i studied the
metric system guys
and the problem was the teachers
couldn't just give you a straight answer
they they were always like okay kids
you want to know what a meter is well
you know what a football field looks
like don't y'all
take that divide by a hundred then go a
little bit less
wha what uh uh and
what about the kilogram that's super
easy kilogram is 2.2 pounds but they
could never say that
they always said think of a small cat
like oh gosh that's
art and math together guys that's both
the lobes i i can't get both the lobes
to work
unless i put my finger in an outlet
and pray for an electrical arc well
thanks for having me you guys
i literally i'm gonna send that set to
all my friends right now